[Musik]
als Vertreter aus der Direktion Einsatz
darf ich ein generalmannschaft
und als heerespsychologin Wolfgang Prinz
begrüßen Frau Verteidigungsminister
suchen vielen Dank sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren
medienvertreterinnenvertreter sehr
geehrter Herr Generalmajor Herr Magister
Prinz zunächst mal vielen vielen Dank
dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben
und heute hier bei uns im
Verteidigungsministerium sind ich darf
Sie ganz herzlich begrüßen zu unserem
bilanzschuh fix das ist ein neues Format
mit dem wir die Öffentlichkeit
insbesondere sie über die Öffentlichkeit
in regelmäßigen Abständen informieren
wollen über aktuelle Zahlen über
Einsätze über Entwicklungen im
österreichischen Bundesheer bzw im
verteidigungsresort ich denke das ist
insofern in einer Zeit die weltweit von
sicherheitspolitischen Veränderungen und
Herausforderungen
Objekt ist uns alle vor Probleme stellt
bzw gestellt hat auch unabdingbar
notwendig ja Herausforderungen hatten
wir als österreichisches Bundesheer
unglaublich viele zu bewältigen begonnen
von der corona-pandemie den
Terroranschlag bis zum Angriffskrieg
Putins auf die Ukraine der nicht nur
unsägliches Leid gebracht hat sondern
auch eine Energiekrise Teuerung und
Inflation mit sich gebracht hat
daraufhin haben sich die Staaten
Europäischen Union bis hin zu den NATO
Ländern entschlossen die
verteidigungsetats aufzustocken um sich
auf vorzubereiten auf diese neuen
Herausforderungen so haben auch wir das
gemacht wir konnten in den letzten
Jahren das Budget stufenweise erhöhen
und mit dem Jahr 2022 haben wir es
Bundesheer eine durchaus enorme Erhöhung
des Verteidigungsbudgets erfahren mit
der 16 Milliarden allein
alleine in den nächsten vier Jahren auch
abgesichert durch ein
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
diese Erhöhung die hat uns Möglichkeiten
geschaffen neue Möglichkeiten damit wir
das Bundesheer auch in ein modernes
Zeitalter führen können das reicht von
der vom Schutz und Wirkung der Soldaten
diesen Investitionen wie zum Beispiel
den erst kürzlich übergebenen
Sturmgewehren modifizierten STG 77 bis
hin zur Mobilität der Truppe zu Lande
und zu Luft wir haben erst vor zwei
Wochen den zweiten Leonardo Hubschrauber
an die Truppe in eigen übergeben dürfen
insgesamt ist das ein Investment von 873
Millionen Euro für gesamt 36
Hubschrauber das ist die zweitgrößte
Flotte die es eben Bundesheer gegeben
hat wir haben im gepanzerten Bereich
bereits hunderte Pandur beschafft
weiterer werden noch folgen und auch der
Erneuerung unserer Schützen und
Kampfpanzer ist der fixiert die ersten
beiden Schützenpanzer Ulan sind bereits
die Ingenieure der Firma general dynamic
European lanc Systems Steyr GmbH
übergeben worden auch das ist ein
Investitionsvolumen von 560 Millionen
Euro das heißt insgesamt werden dann 170
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge modernisiert ja und
auch was unsere Kasernen anbelangt
kommen wir voran erst letzte Woche haben
wir den Spatenstich für die Sanierung
des Wirtschaftsgebäudes in der
zehnerkaserne in Ried im Innkreis
gesetzt wo wir 10,5 Millionen Euro
investieren wir haben auch weitere
größere Bauprojekte in Wiener Neustadt
laufen in der donkaserne 57 Millionen
Euro für den Neubau von
Wirtschaftsgebäuden unterkunftsgebäuden
in holzmodulweise auch das ist so uns
ein Anliegen und auch den Schülerinnen
und Schülern der örtlichen
sicherheitsschule eine moderne
Bildungsraum zu schaffen sie wissen dass
wir in Villach ein Großprojekt haben
über 120 Millionen Euro werden
investiert für eine eine großkaserne in
Mistelbach Niederösterreich überhaupt
seit Jahrzehnten der erste Neubau einer
Kaserne in Mistelbach ja und in Wien
schreiten wir auch voran mit dem
Bauarbeiten für die
neuungsstraße im sanitätszentrum Ost in
der
vansiten-kaserne das sollen künftig
Wiener und hoffentlich bald auch
WienerInnen wenn sie dann sich für den
freiwilligen grundwehrdienste für Frauen
entscheiden den wir ja April einführen
auf Herz und Nieren untersuchte werden
ja und wir haben auch eines gemacht
letztes Jahr erneut unsere Befragung zum
sozialen Lagebild 2022 über diese
Ergebnisse wird dann im Anschluss auch
Magister Wolfgang prinzer berichten das
ist für uns eine ganz wichtige Befragung
die insbesondere zu einer
Entscheidungsgrundlage dient damit wir
uns auch als Resort wirkungsvoll besser
aufstellen können nachhaltig gestalten
können ähm die aktuelle Befragung war
eine sehr große mit 4.500 Grundwert in
der Milizsoldaten Bediensteten ein
Dokument das uns wirklich auch hilft
beim Ausbau der notwendigen Maßnahmen
und bei der Weiterentwicklung unseres
Ressorts zu einem modernen und
insbesondere auch glaubwürdigen
Arbeitgeber ja sie sehen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren unsere Mission vorwärts
die macht Fortschritte sie können sich
sicher sein wir werden diesen Weg auch
gemeinsam weitergehen aber eine steht
auch außer Frage es gibt unglaublich
vieles zu tun wir dürfen nicht vergessen
darauf dass unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten durch die zahlreichen ja
Einsätze rund um die Uhr im Inland im
Ausland für unsere Sicherheit sorgen
dass das auch dementsprechende Folgen
nach sich zieht auch darüber werden wir
noch sprechen das wird ihnen dann her
generalma ja Christina mehr präsentieren
danke schön
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich darf
kurz über die laufenden Einsätze des
Bundesheers berichten ich beginne im
Inland wie aktuell etwa etwas über 1200
Soldaten im Assistenzeinsatz im Inland
davon etwa 98 hier im Großraum Wien wie
unterstützen die Exekutive bei der
Überwachung von Botschaften diversen
öffentlichen Gebäuden und die Masse
nämlich über 1100 haben wir im
sicherheitspolizeilichen Assistenzarzt
entlang der Grenzen das Schwerpunkt
liegt im Burgenland mit über 700
eingesetzten Soldaten darüber hinaus die
Steiermark Kärnten und Tirol mit jeweils
etwa 130 bis 150 wir leisten damit ein
wesentlichen Beitrag dazu dass andere
Behörden Ihren Auftrag erfüllen kann
können ich möchte aber nicht
unverhältnissen dass sich das natürlich
wenn sich das in die Länge zieht und
erhebliche Stärken beansprucht dass sich
das auch negativ auf die Organisation
auswirkt eines der größten Themen bei
uns in der Landwirtschaften derzeit ist
der fähigkeitsverlust weil wir all diese
Soldaten und Soldaten ja der Ausspielung
entziehen müssen die gehen
durchschnittlich für etwa drei Monate in
den Assistenzeinsatz und das hat
natürlich Auswirkungen auch auf die
beaderung in der Miliz aber natürlich
letztendlich auch auf den
Ausbildungsstand des Kader Personals
übrigens sehr stolz immer auf den
belize-beitrag die Miliz leistet ein
wesentlichen Beitrag etwa 50% der
eingesetzten Kräfte im Inland kommen aus
der Miliz aktuell 646 und wir haben
aktuell auch etwa 270 grundverdiener im
Einsatz daneben gibt es noch eine kleine
negative Auswirkung wir haben sehr viele
Freiwillige für den Inlandseinsatz wir
tun uns ein bisschen schwerer dadurch
für oder beim Auslandseinsatz das
entsprechende Personal zu finden daher
ist das so dass wir Schultern mit dem
Innenministerium jetzt Möglichkeiten
abwägen die Gesamtstärke etwas
zurückzufahren trotzdem auch noch den
entsprechenden Aufträge zu finden ich
darf kurz informieren es gibt diverse
Unterstützungsleistung wir haben jetzt
also Nutzungsvereinbarung insgesamt acht
Stück mit dem bei mir abgeschlossen das
Innenministerium wird in Zukunft
vermehrt Einrichtung des
österreichischen Bundesheers im Rahmen
der Ausbildung und der Schießausbildung
nutzen ich darf informieren über den
Entminungsdienst man glaubt es kaum das
ist nur einige dieser Events schlagen
medial auf pro Tag durchschnittlich etwa
zwei bis drei Einsätze des
entmündungsdienstes der ersten Sena
insgesamt 173 wir haben übrigens die
Masse der Einsätze hier im Bundesland
der Niederösterreich mit 79 gefolgt von
Oberösterreich 32 und der Rest verteilt
sich auf die anderen Bundesländer es
wird hier Munition
Granaten Bomben aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg mit Wasser geworden insgesamt
bislang in den ersten zweieinhalb
Monaten dieses Jahres achteinhalb Tonnen
die werden dann bei uns auf
entsprechenden Übungsplätze verbracht
und dort entsprechend davon Vernichtung
zugeführt
ich dafür die Auslandseinsätze berichten
wir haben laufend zwischen 800 bis zu
1000 Soldaten ihnen setzen das ist eine
Erfolgsgeschichte des österreichischen
Bundesheer seit 1960 beteiligen wir uns
an über 100
einsatzräumen und Missionen zum
friedenserhalt in keiner Teilbereichen
auch zufrieden schaffenden Maßnahmen und
wir sind dabei ständig im Spitzenfeld im
ersten obersten Viertel der Europäischen
Union was die Zahl der eingesetzten
Soldat im Auslandseinsatz in Relation
zur Einwohnerzahl anlangt aktuell sind
wir in 13 einsatzräumen tätig darüber
hinaus haben wir ein militärisches
krisenunterstützungsteam in der Ukraine
zu Unterstützung der dortigen Botschaft
die Stärke schwankt also zwischen 800
bis 100 wir haben aktuell 27 Damen im
Auslandseinsatz das ist ein Rundfunk für
uns da wollen wir die Zahl entsprechen
steigern und man darf nicht vergessen
auch dort der milizanteil derzeit 27%
voriges Jahr haben Kopf vier Monate da
waren wir bei knapp 40 % milizanteil
also ohne die Beteiligung der Militär
könnten wir diese Einsätze in dieser
Stärke nicht fahren
ich darf vielleicht noch informieren
über den lawineneinsatz wir haben es
über die Winterzeit traditionell in
Österreich insgesamt 9
lawineneinsatzzüge die wir bereithalten
darüber auch eine hinaus einige
spezialisierte lawineneinsatzgruppen das
sind insgesamt über 400 soldatum
Soldaten und dies abgerufen werden
können heuer zum Glück noch keinen
Einsatz der letzte beim Dezember letzten
Jahr sind Vorarlberg wo wir 80 Personen
zum Einsatz gebracht haben um
verschüttete zu suchen
ich darf noch informieren über den
stellungsbetrieb ich bin Bundesheer auch
zuständig für die Koordinierung der
sechs stellungsstraßen wir haben
insgesamt den sechs Bundesländern diese
stellungsstraße und bedingt durch die
Pandemie ist immer ein bisschen in
Verzug geraten wir haben 2020 am
Höhepunkt der ersten Welle der Pandemie
den stellungsbetrieb für etwa
zweieinhalb Monate unterbrechen müssen
und wir können wir haben heute davon
Bundesminister schon gemeldet mit diesem
Monat also jetzt mit märz haben wir
diesen Überhang wieder abgebaut und da
sind sozusagen wieder im planmäßigen
Betrieb wir haben heuer bereits über
11.000 Stellungspflichtige bei unseren
stellungsstraßen untersuchen können wir
haben davon einen tauglichkeitsanteil
von 65% etwa knapp 20% sind
vorübergehend sind untauglich von
vornherein und dann gibt es ein
Prozentsatz des vorübergehend
unglaublich das bedeutet sie werden
Nachuntersuchungen zugeführt und es gibt
eine Erfolgsmeldung aus unserer Sicht
hat ein bisschen Seltenheitswert der
zivildienstanteil bislang in den ersten
dreieinhalb Monate waren nur etwa 19
Prozent das ist gut für uns es ist aber
so dass sie der im Jahre Schnitt
einpendelt etwa auf rund 45 Prozent plus
minus eins zwei Prozent im Jahre schnitt
ich darf noch zu einem ganz wichtigen
Punkt für uns kommen wir haben jetzt die
herrliche Situation dass wir endlich
altes Gerät ersetzen können sehr viel
dazu kommt dass man etwas im Bereich der
Infrastruktur machen können die Frau
Bundesminister trotz dargestellt große
Sorgen haben wir natürlich auch wie alle
öffentlichen Einrichtungen im
Personalbereich und das ist momentan
einer die Mission vorwärts wurde schon
angesprochen von der Frau Bundesminister
einer unserer Schwergewichte die
personalwerbung muss auch sagen wir
haben insbesondere bei den
unterschiedlichen etwas Sorge und es ist
für uns eine volksmeldung wir konnten
also ersten ungefähr 420 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten in österreichischen Bundeswehr
aufnehmen darüber hinaus haben wir 110
Männer und 13 Damen in den
Ausbildungsdienst übernehmen können und
wir haben insgesamt seit erstem
00 Rekruten einberufen für den
grundverdienst die personelle
Einsatzbereitschaft die sehr gut und wir
setzen derzeit sehr viele Maßnahmen und
mein gutes Angebot und Paket zu
entwickeln um mehr junge Menschen
begeistern zu können für einen Dienst im
Bundestag danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
danke sehr und wie sieht diese
Einsatzzahlen auch auf das soziale
Lagebild beim Bundeswehr auswirken
wirklich den heeresspsychologischen
Experten im Bereich der Sozialforschung
Magister Wolfgang Prinz und seine
Ausführungen suchen ja sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesminister sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren das verteidigungsresort führt
seit 2016 ein sehr innovatives Tool
durch oder betreiben sie innovatives
Tool nämlich die regelmäßigen
Befragungen zum sozialen Lagebild zur
Beschreibung des personellen und
sozialen Zustands im weitesten Sinne im
ressortbereich das primäre Ziel dieses
Tools ist es evidenzbasierte
Entscheidungsgrundlagen für die
strategische ressortführung
bereitzustellen und ich darf Ihnen heute
auszugsweise die aus unserer Sicht
wesentlichsten Ergebnisse aus dem
Vorjahr darstellen wir haben also im
Juni des vergangenen Jahres 4.500
grundbediener befragt darüber hinaus
3900 Angehörige der Miliz und im
September Dauer des vergangenen Jahres
1200 Bedienstete das heißt
berufssoldatinnen und Soldaten wie auch
Zivilbedienstete zusätzlich
interessieren wir uns nicht nur für die
Innensicht sozusagen auf das
österreichische Bundesheer für die Sicht
unseres Personals sondern auch für die
externe Sichtweise auf unsere
Organisation das bedeutet auch für die
Bevölkerung Sichtweise da darf ich Ihnen
auch ganz knapp die wesentlichsten
Ergebnisse aus dem Feuer zusammenfassen
zu den Ergebnissen ich möchte beginnen
mit einem Bereich der für das
österreichische Bundesheer sehr
wesentlich ist das ist der
Ausbildungsbereich und da sehen wir
erfreulicherweise dass im vergangenen
Jahr die Zufriedenheit mit der
Ausbildung bzw auch mit der Ausfahrt und
Weiterbildung im österreichischen
Bundesheer hoch bisher hoch war in allen
Befragten Personengruppen ist ein sehr
erfreuliches Ergebnis ein weiterer
wesentlicher Bereich betrifft das
Verhältnis zu den direkten Vorgesetzten
da interessieren uns natürlich ganz
besonders auch wie die Grundwehrdiener
mit dem Ausbildungspersonal sozusagen
zurechtkommen wie das Verhältnis zum
Ausbildungspersonal ist und auch da
sehen wir dass wie bereits in den
vergangenen Jahren im weitesten Sinne
des Verhältnis zu den direkten
Vorgesetzten als sehr sehr positiv
beschrieben wird ich darf während dessen
auszugsweise kurz darstellen zum
Beispiel sagen 80 Prozent der
grundverdiener dass sie ein gutes
Verhältnis zum direkten Vorgesetzten
haben knapp dreiviertel der Bediensteten
90% der milizangehörigen also das sind
schon zahlen die ein sehr klares Bild
liefern wir erfassen auch die
Arbeitszufriedenheit im Resort und da
sehen wir dass es so insgesamt über alle
Personengruppen hinweg betrachtet der
Arbeit Zufriedenheit weitgehend stabil
ist wir haben aber auch
Optimierungsbedarf festgestellt und das
betrifft vor allem zwei Bereiche zum
einen die Grundwehrdiener da sehen wir
dass diese im vergangenen Jahr ganz
besonders durch die Inflation und die
Teuerung betroffen waren
zum anderen eine andere Personengruppe
nämlich unser Kaderpersonal das heißt
die berufssoldatinnen und Soldaten da
beobachten wir dass die Anforderungen
der vergangenen Jahre
österreichische Bundesheer ganz
besonders in den vergangenen Jahren wie
auch andere Einsatzorganisationen im
Zuge der Krisenbewältigung sehr
gefordert und das Sehen wird dass diese
Anforderungen auch mit Herausforderungen
für unsere Personal verbunden waren
besonders was die Vereinbarkeit von
Beruf und Privatleben betrifft das noch
hinzukommt ist ein gesellschaftlicher
Trend der in den letzten Jahren ja
medial und wissenschaftlich auch schon
breit diskutiert worden ist Stichwort
Generation Zeit den spüren wir auch das
bedeutet wir sehen vor allem bei unseren
jüngeren Personengruppen eine veränderte
Anspruchshaltung und eine höhere
berufliche
Veränderungsbereitschaft als das früher
der Fall war
was uns dennoch in dem Zusammenhang
positiv stimmt ist dass das
österreichische Bundesheer von unseren
Personal mehrheitlich auch im letzten
Jahr als attraktiver Arbeitgeber erlebt
wird auf der einen Seite auf der anderen
Seite sehen wir in den vergangenen
Jahren und es ist auch letztes Jahr der
Fall einen sehr sehr ausgeprägten
sozialen Zusammenhalt eine sehr sehr
hohe gegenseitige
unterstützungsbereitschaft im Ressort
Stichwort Kollegialität und
Kameradschaft das ist für uns vor allem
aus einer psychologischen Perspektive
ein ganz ganz wesentlicher Faktor weil
es eine sehr sehr klare Evidenz gibt das
social support wie wir sagen also
soziale Unterstützung im Kollegenkreis
ganz wesentlich ist bei der Bewältigung
von Herausforderungen die aus einsetzen
resultieren
Vorletzter Punkt darf ich noch eine
Personengruppe herausgreifen nämlich die
Miliz wir befragen die militzeit 2021
haben wir letztes Jahr die zweite
befragen durchgeführt und da sehen wir
in vielen vielen Bereichen positive
Entwicklungen die man zusammenfassen
könnte durchaus mit einer Art von
Aufbruchstimmung die die Stimmung oder
die Stimmungsbild in der Miliz sozusagen
charakterisiert das betrifft die
Zufriedenheit mit der konkreten
Verwendung als milizsalat aber auch
andere Bereiche und zu guter Letzt wie
ich angekündigt habe auch die externe
Sichtweise auf unsere Organisation auf
das Resort die wesentlichsten Ergebnisse
aus unserem bevölkerungsbefragungen
lassen sich damit zusammenfassen dass
wir nach wie vor in etwa wie auch in den
vergangenen Jahren sehen dass zwei
Drittel der österreichischen Bevölkerung
eine positive Grundhaltung zum
österreichischen Bundesheer haben ganz
wesentliches Ergebnis und dann darf ich
Ihnen noch zu guter Letzt ein besonderes
Ergebnis herausgreifen aus dem März des
vergangenen Jahres ist schon eine Weile
her aber war für uns ein ganz Wesen
tliches Ergebnis wir haben auch mit dem
Thema der geistigen Landesverteidigung
befasst und haben im März das
vergangenen Jahres die Bevölkerung
gefragt wie stehen sie denn zur
Informationsarbeit an den Schulen und
damals knapp 90% der österreichischen
Bevölkerung der Befragten in dem Fall
angegeben das sehr sehr eine Information
von Schülerinnen und Schülern über
singen und Aufgaben des Bundesheeres in
der Schule befürworten da haben wir als
einen ganz ganz hohen Rückhalt in der
Bevölkerung
ja vielen Dank Herr Magister Prinz sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir haben sehr
viele sehr freundliches gehört
insbesondere die beeindruckende Zahl der
bedeutenden Bedeutung der geistigen
Landesverteidigung das sind wir mit
Sicherheit auf einem richtigen Weg weil
es uns gemeinsam mit dem
Bildungsminister gelungen ist dass auch
in den Lehrplänen erstmaliger wieder zu
verankern erfreuliche sicher auch der
Bereich der Ausbildung und die
Zufriedenheit damit alles was den
Bereich der Miliz und der Herr Magister
Prinz hat Aufbruchstimmung dazu gesagt
wie das angekommen ist was wir hier
alles schon umgesetzt haben auch
optimistischer kann unser Stimmen der
der soziale Zusammenhalt die
Bereitschaft auch zur gegenseitigen
Unterstützung insgesamt eben bei allen
Personengruppen und natürlich eben auch
die gesellschaftliche Anerkennung des
Bundesheeres das kennen wir durchaus
oder sie bereits auch aus verschiedenen
anderen Umfragen das was wir aber auch
sehen und ich glaube
wir die Augen nicht verschließen ist da
dass das Lagebild auch einen
Optimierungsbedarf aufzeigt den wir sehr
ernster nehmen müssen sehr ernst nehmen
müssen wenn wir wirklich dieses
Instrumentarium dieses sozialen
Lageberichtes auch wirklich verwenden
wollen diese Art der Umfragen führt
eigentlich kein anderes Resort meinen
Informationen nach durch und so müssen
wir bei den Kleinsten Erschütterungen
schon regulierend eingreifen bevor dann
ein größerer Schaden auch entsteht es
sind insbesondere bei den grundwertinnen
angesprochen worden die Auswirkungen der
Teuerung der Inflation wie sind
erläutert worden ich glaube da haben wir
schon rechtzeitig reagiert darauf weil
wir dann auch ein neues Modell der
Vergütung unserer Grundwehrdiener
eingeführt haben wir haben erstmalig
nach beinahe einem Jahrzehnt eben den
sollt auch angehoben für die
Grundwehrdiener ich glaube das war ein
sehr sehr wichtiger und richtiger auch
Schritt
haben wie gesagt auch die Möglichkeit
der freiwilligen Stellung eben das
Freiwilligen grundwertdienstes für
Frauen auch eingeführt und wir dürfen
auch eines nicht vergessen wenn man sich
die Einsatzzahlen die vom Herrn
generalmayr präsentiert worden sind
anschaut dann sieht man dass unsere
berufssoldatinnen und Soldaten in den
vergangenen Jahren mit so vielen Krisen
konfrontiert waren die Sie wirklich
vorher Herausforderungen gestellt haben
dass auch mit dem Privatleben mit dem
Familienleben zu vereinbaren das sind
Einsätze die auf der über Nacht
angeordnet werden ohne einer gewissen
Planbarkeit das dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen und was wir auch nicht
vergessen dürfen wir müssen uns auch
wieder darauf konzentrieren was unsere
Kernaufgaben sind das ist die
militärische Landesverteidigung und das
sicherzustellen müssen wir wieder
vermehrt Übungen durchführen sie wissen
wir haben für das Jahr 2024 eine große
Übung Schutzschild 20 24 geplant und wir
müssen noch daran arbeiten
weiterarbeiten dass die einsatzlast und
die Belastung für unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten insbesondere bei den
assistenzeinsätzen reduziert wird dort
wo es sinnvoll und wo es möglich ist und
selbstverständlich in Absprache mit dem
Bundesministerium für Inneres das ist ja
teilweise bei der botschaftsbewachung
schon umgesetzter worden ja und ich
glaube auch was die Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf anbelangt müssen wir
entsprechende Maßnahmen setzen
insbesondere auch was die
Kinderbetreuung anbelangt wir haben vor
dass wir bei jeder Kaserne die wir neu
bauen die wir umbauen auch eine
kinderbetreuungsstätte von vornherein
auch mit planen damit wir den Frauen den
Soldatinnen aber auch den Männern die
Sorge und den Stress rund um die Kind
Kinderbetreuung auch nehmen ja ich denke
wir tragen auch sehr viel Hoffnung in
unser Wasser den freiwilligen Grundwert
ist für Frauen anbelangt der ja mit
ersten April an startet mit auch großen
werbe-maßnahmen ich glaube ein sehr sehr
wichtiger Schritt dass wir hier diese
bis dato wirklich hohen
Einstiegsbarrieren massiv auch gelockert
haben aber insgesamt oder der General
mehr als auch angesprochen steht es
außer Frage dass wir egal ob wir
weiblich oder männlich das ist eine
Herausforderung ist das ist eine
Herausforderung ist besser neigt
gewinnen zu können zum einen einmal aber
dann auch dieses halten zu können gerade
bei den Frauen ist die Drop-out-Rate
wirklich hoch und daher haben wir auch
entsprechende Maßnahmen gesetzt und das
sind doch noch einige notwendig um eine
Trendumkehr auch einzuleiten damit
müssen wir uns laufend beschäftigen das
tun wir in den verschiedensten Bereichen
wir müssen wie jedes andere Unternehmen
um jede einzelne und jeden einzelnen
Soldaten sie will Bediensteten Soldatin
kämpfen weiterhin auch
Maßnahmen setzen auch neue Wege
beschreiten wie wir es in dem einen oder
anderen Bereich schon getan haben und
uns auch um die Zufriedenheit unserer
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter ganz
besonders kümmern damit diese weiter
erhalten bleibt bzw damit wir diese noch
steigern können vielen Dank
zunächst zum Auslandseinsatz es ist
richtig das ist eine Herausforderung die
personalwerbung der Hauptgrund liegt
darin dass wir einen relativ hohen
Personalbedarf hier im bei den Irland
einsetzen fahren und das genau die
Klientel ist die sich sonst traditionell
für die Auslandseinsätze melde ich sage
jetzt mal wir haben das im Griff aber
das ist mit einer der Gründe warum wir
auch in Interesse haben die
inlandseinsätze zurück zu fahren aber
was die Stärke des zurückfahrens anlang
die Milland ist so dass wir mit dem bei
mir jetzt einige Verhandlungsrunden
hatten ich glaube sehr gute Lösungen das
wird jetzt durch die militärkommanden
durch die vier Einsatz führenden mit den
Landespolizei Direktion im Detail
abgestimmt ich kann da jetzt also noch
keine Zahlen nennen wir werden in etwa
drei bis vier Wochen die Endergebnisse
haben und wir werden diese Stärke
Reduzierung im zweiten Quartal also bis
Mitte des Jahres realisiert haben
nachdem es keine weiteren Fragen gibt
bedanke ich mich recht herzlich und
schließe damit die Presse vorbei danke
schön